[Music]
okay everyone i'm really excited today
because i am joined by
grace van patten aka gvp aka cassie
and the violent heart this movie is
coming out tomorrow on demand and in
theaters
grace how you doing today i'm good i'm
good i'm
i'm here in brooklyn new york i just got
back from australia so i'm a little
i'm a little uh jet lagged so excuse me
but um i'm excited to be back be back
home
no that's awesome to hear i'm in white
plains new york so i'm a fellow new
yorker so
nice i can yeah so you're ready for the
snowstorm coming soon another one
oh man i didn't even know that uh yeah
we got to stay inside anyway so i guess
yeah and
there's the reason for people to watch
this movie and you know
i really enjoyed watching this film uh
it was such an awesome performance by
you as cassie here
and it's interesting because when i was
doing my research for this interview i
read that
at a young age you actually had a mini
chopper
and i was wondering if you can confirm
this because in the movie
there's multiple scenes you're on a
motorcycle so was this scary for you or
is this like old hat like that's easy
for you
it's it felt pretty comfortable on the
bike that that is true
my my mom and her whole side of the
family are complete
bikers um and my mom had a motorcycle
when she was like six years old and she
kind of
passed that down to us i've never ridden
a motorcycle in the city
so it's always been in florida i would
be too scared to do that but that is
that is true so it felt felt good to be
back
okay that's yeah i was wondering because
any time i see a motorcycle scene i'm
like are these
actors like scared out of their minds i
would be but that's cool that you had
like experience with it and i also
wonder too
with your technique as an actress do you
go like to a lot of lengths with prep
like did you make
a back story for cassie are you kind of
do a little more simple um well with
this it was so great because we all
we all got to nashville you know um
a couple weeks before we started
shooting and we really
had like jovan and karen and i really
hashed out and made sure the romance was
there and that they had
their dynamic going because that was the
you know the heart of the story so
in terms of prep it was really with them
and with jovan and
talking about every scene before we did
it and really making sure we were on the
same page which helped
so much so yeah no and that really shows
you guys have really good chemistry
together and with that chemistry you
guys have is that
as an actress when you're meeting your
co-lead here to have chemistry did you
guys have to do chemistry tests or you
kind of just jump into it and let kind
of things naturally come yeah we
actually did which i
i had never done before and i i feel
like it's so necessary and it was um
it was so great we had a chemistry and
actually i was when i was sitting
outside the chemistry rooted
um i was like sitting on my phone i
think it was texting my boyfriend i see
at this point i did not know toby
mcguire was one of the producers
okay i am walking down the street and
i'm like holy
and i [ __ ] it's my boyfriend and then
and then he goes
hey grace and i'm like what is happening
and and then slowly i realized holy [ __ ]
he's part of this movie this is so
exciting and then we go inside i was a
little bit nervous for that but
um then the chemistry happened and jovan
was amazing and it was kind of just
i think we all knew right away and um
we kind of talked before we went into
the room and did the scenes so
it felt good it felt right right away no
that's awesome and that totally stands
out too like when you watch this film in
the credits you see toby maguire's name
as a producer it's always exciting to
just think of spider-man
you know but that's really cool and
when you pick this script like are you
as an actress picky with scripts is
there like red flags you see
or like was there something about this
script that made you want to do it that
stood out to you
i've always been in love with romance
thrillers they're my favorite types of
movies and um
you know i love badlands and natural
born killer i've just always been drawn
to that and have always wanted to do
something like that so i think
instantly i was kind of hooked before i
even read the script
um i usually just fall in love with
the character and kind of go with that
um i also just thought it was different
in the way that
in most romance movies the couple meets
and their
their lives ultimately just kind of get
better from there
where in this case it's like they meet
and life comes
tumbling down on them and um but they
still serve as this
beautiful escape for one another so i
really was drawn to that
to that yeah more real to me so
sure and i think people looking for a
movie that's what makes this an exciting
one it made me excited to watch it is it
has that blend of genre really well and
it makes it extra like exciting to see
where we'll go and mystery
so uh but you know
i i wonder too like when you do these
performances and you're not a stranger
to being on different platforms like
you've had experience on netflix and
do you go and watch your performance
after like do you kick your feet up and
are you gonna download this movie or do
you
not like watching yourself on screen i
have a hard time
but um it
usually i i'm forced to see it by going
to a premiere
or going to a festival or something you
know but
i feel like in this case it's all in my
control so i i don't know what i'm gonna
do it's it
definitely the first time i watch
something it's i can't
process anything so it if anything it
takes me a few times but
um no i'm excited i'm really excited to
to watch it again i've only seen it once
um and that one time i couldn't take
anything in so
i'm ready for the snowstorm will will
inspire me
hell yeah and uh it's interesting
switching gears are big i wanted to
bring up two what's awesome it's one of
my favorite lists and you made it in
2017 in variety
where you were one of 10 actors to watch
when that was announced can you tell me
did that add pressure to you or did that
just motivate you even more in your
career
oh that was so that was a really
exciting time
um because tramps the first movie i ever
did
really um came out and that was the best
experience i've
ever um and then the meyer with stories
came out so it was kind of
two two things i had done that
had been a while had been a while then
you know since i made them and
um everything kind of just started
happening and i
i really loved making those movies and
um
it felt really good that that people um
also loved them so it definitely
motivated me and
um it's it's all exciting every step of
the way
really it's been really no yeah and it's
exciting to watch your journey as an
actress because you started at a younger
age i mean you were even on the set of
the sopranos right when you were like
eight
so that's an awesome experience and and
knowing that it's cool because you can
already
come off like a pro and a vet even
though you're younger but
you have so much experience already and
i think um
what i have to ask too that you you know
grew up around people in the industry
was there any thoughts in your mind like
maybe i don't want to do acting was
there something else you might have
wanted to do like a different career
sure i went through a big phase of
wanting to do
anything but that because my whole
you know my whole dad's side was in the
business so
i really kind of tried to steer away
from it but just as a rebellious thing i
think i've always loved it and always
wanted to do it
and i was always doing plays in school
and
doing acting class in school and then it
kind of
hit me after high school
um that's when i was like okay i wanna i
really wanna sink my teeth into this and
go for it but i think that it just took
confidence because i think because i
had seen behind the scenes i knew how
hard it was and i knew it wasn't
as glamorous as people thought so
i didn't um crave that aspect of it and
i knew that
was such a small part of it so i think
it took me a while to build
and and also just for people to have
confidence in me you know in high school
i think
i got my manager right out of high
school and um
it took someone to to believe in me to
make me want to go go for it so
yeah and that's interesting too when
you're talking about like
having that experience seeing things
behind the scenes is not as glamorous as
it is
now speaking of behind the scenes when
you're on set now today
um do you ever have thoughts of wanting
to also direct or write and are you one
of those actors that kind of peeks
around and sees what everyone else is
doing are you kind of like oh right now
i'm zoned in on acting only like what's
your
favorite right now as of the past few
jobs i definitely
have i think i've always been terrified
of directing i i just can't even wrap my
head around ever being able to do it but
i am i am
so interested and um curious
and and the past few jobs i really have
been watching
because that is definitely a dream of
mine to
to do it all really but but to learn
about it first and
and there's no better place than to be
on set and just kind of
watch so oh yeah for sure and then
so when you're not on set and we're in
this crazy
two years we've been in what does grace
pass the time with like are you a big
reader you have a bunch of books behind
you or
yeah i'm in an airbnb so i can't protect
let's just say damn okay this is my
library
oh no but i i was in australia for the
past eight months so i
luckily skipped out on eight months of
of hell
and was in australia where there's there
was no covid where i was
and life was weirdly normal
but um my boyfriend came out there and
we lived in a van
for for three and a half weeks and drove
along the coast of australia and it was
the best time
i've ever had um and that was definitely
a shock in so many ways but now i'm i
even coming back to new york i'm
there's there's too much stimulation i'm
like i just want to go
crawl back into the small metal tin box
that i lived in
um and that was that was just beautiful
and i and it weirdly i think prepared me
for coming back to new york and being
inside isolated because all i want to do
is just listen to podcasts and read
and watch so i'm
that's what i'm going to do yeah so is
there anything because i think fans
always want to hear like what their
favorite actors actresses like
enjoy is there anything recently a movie
or show you watch that you
kind of were obsessed with or dug yeah
i'm i'm obsessed with i may destroy you
um okay it was so
so good and so powerful and so important
i
highly highly recommend recommend that
um
and i just started re-watching killing
eve because i am
obsessed with that and my boyfriend is
never so i'm
watching it through and it's even better
so i love that i like yeah
no that's awesome and those are great
recommendations for people
uh so you know the most thing i was
excited about talking to you today was
that like for me
this is a huge year for you it's like
the year of grayson and pad because you
got mayday just premiered at sundance
and then i have to bring it up because
you mentioned australia i'm gonna guess
that you were working on nine perfect
strangers for hulu yeah
so when i saw your cast in that that's
really exciting you're actually one of
the perfect strangers um
and working along you know nicole kidman
melissa mccarthy
is there anything you can tell us about
it that it's gonna be great or anything
i'm really excited about it it's it's
based off of a book
which you can read to get a little sneak
peek but um it definitely took its own
course in the show but um
it has it really has everything i mean
it's
it's so funny all the actors are so
amazing i mean it was just
a master class being on that set but um
it's funny it's heartbreaking it's weird
it's scary it's it's so many things
combined but
the the basic kind of premise of it is
um
nicole kidman is running this retreat
wellness retreat
um and nine different people
um they're all coming from different
places with different problems
i go with my family with my parents um
because i had a brother that
committed suicide three years prior um
and
were going for grieving and trying to
heal
um and everyone else is there for
different reasons and all
hell kind of breaks loose so i am i'm
very excited and curious to see how it
turns out hopefully
hopefully
it that's so exciting to hear and and
i'm just the last question about it can
you confirm that filming's done
you guys no more filming yeah we're done
i will i'm here
i hope not okay so
before i let you go grace um what would
you say for people who are thinking
about watching this movie
why should they watch this film what
what is it about it that will be fresh
to them or
kind of suck them in you think i think
i think as crazy and twisted and
absurd as it is i think people can
relate to it because i think
i do think ultimately it is a film about
loss and and every character goes
through loss
in it and they all cope with it in
different ways and
they're all different types of loss and
i think
anyone on any scale can connect with
that so
um also it's fun it's fun to watch and
it's
cool and there's romance and there's
thrill
and there's everything so sit back
and enjoy
hell yeah and uh you heard it from her
that's the best seller you're gonna get
it comes
out tomorrow the violin heart in
theaters and on demand if you're snowed
in definitely
give it a good rental uh grace thank you
so much for
joining me and i hope to talk to you
again in the future yes thank you so
much
so nice talking to you